so republican senator mitt romney was
brutally booed
and according to people in the room
called a traitor
by republicans at the utah state
republican convention this weekend you
have to hear this
and this we're kind of on a search for
answers to a very seemingly simple
question that question is
whether the republican party is the
party of donald trump is it still the
party of donald trump or
will the republican party go back to
being the party of someone like
mitt romney people like romney john
mccain and the like
one data point has been the really
consistent polling where the vast
majority of the republican electorate
still says
we like trump we believe trump won in
2020. we would vote for trump again we
want trump to remain involved in
politics
that's one data point utah held its
republican convention this weekend
and there was not only an attempt to
censure mitt romney
by republicans which almost passed more
on that in a second
romney was extensively booed by his
own fellow republicans interrupting his
speech multiple times
take a look at this video take a listen
to this audio
[Applause]
so what do you think about president
biden's first hundred days
now you know me as a person who who says
what he thinks and i don't hide the fact
that i wasn't a fan of our last
president's character issues
and i'm also no fan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
aren't you embarrassed
and i'm also no fan of the yeah that
that is really something else
you know in the relatively anti-trump
republican state of utah
utah is not i don't know what's the
state where i mean like uh
south carolina republicans like trump
much more
than utah republicans like trump um
and even in the relatively
anti-republican trump state of utah
romney is still booed relentlessly
and those very republicans pushed a
motion to censure mitt romney
because he had the audacity to think for
himself in the trump impeachment trials
and vote to convict on some of those
counts so they held the vote to censure
romney it failed but barely 798-711
really
close vote given that these are
supposedly anti-trump republicans
romney reportedly left the venue almost
immediately after finishing his speech
and of course the real question here is
what does this mean for the future of
the republican party
i don't know that it's totally obvious
that rejecting the romney wing
is necessarily bad for the republican
party what i mean by
that is trump individually completely
backfired for republicans
trump got elected in 2016. republicans
lost the house in 2018.
republicans lost the senate in 2020
republicans lost the white house in
2020.
but trumpism and by that i mean
no policy you just fight cultural
battles you oppose the libs
you try to anger people on the left that
may have more staying power
as an approach if people other than
trump are the ones pushing it we just
don't have an answer yet 2022 will be a
partial answer
do people in the romney wing get removed
in 2022
and do people in the trumpian wing
like lauren beaubert madison taylor
greene madison cawthorne
get re-elected notice that mitt romney's
views
have not really changed much since 2012
when he was the republican nominee
most of the people in that room who are
booing him now
if they were old enough to vote in 2012
voted for mitt romney
this is more a sign of how off the deep
end
the republican electorate is it's
similar actually
to remember the situation with the late
senator john mccain
john mccain was a very popular arizona
republican senator
was the republican presidential nominee
in 2008 lost to barack obama
they chose him to be their nominee in
2008 all of them
almost all of them voted for mccain in
the general election
and then just eight years later in 2016
when trump starts with i prefer war
heroes who didn't get captured and
trump ridicules mccain's military
service a lot of those same republicans
were cheering
when donald trump went after mccain in
2016. now
it is true that sarah palin mccain's
vice presidential running mate in 2008
was a sort of proto-trumpian figure
but regardless consider the trajectory
these
same republican voters are now calling
one of their previous nominees a
communist in mitt romney
that all being said trump activated new
people
who never participated in politics
before so some of the booze you're
hearing
are presumably people who simply weren't
engaged at all in 2008 and 2012 but many
were
and now they've decided the people we
thought were the good choices in 2008
and 2012
now we boo them now we call them
communists now we call them traitors
the same republicans who do not care at
all about policy
but are about how bad cancel culture is
now we're loudly trying to cancel
any republican who's even mildly normal
and that's
the way i would describe mitt romney
cautiously i would say he's mildly
normal
2022 is going to be wild and it's going
to be really significant
in terms of the future of the republican
party and we're going to be watching it